according to the consensus of
all of the scholarship of Islam
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
begins this chapter by saying,
oh you who have believed. Do
not proceed in front of Allah
and his messenger. Wording.
There are two different
recitations and two meanings.
The first meaning is do not
precede yourselves ahead of
Allah and his messenger And the
second is do not put anything
or anyone else. And do not give
precedence to anyone or
anything over Allah and his
messenger. Both of these are
intended. Meaning, we ourselves
are not to proceed to do
anything until we know that
Allah has allowed us to do this
until we know that this is
something permissible. We do
not proceed to anything until
we have permission from Allah
and his messenger. Likewise, we
do not give precedence to
anyone's words, to anyone's
will. over the precedence of
Allah and his messenger. So, we
do not obey anyone over Allah
and his messenger. In spite of
Allah and his messenger. No, we
obey Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and his messenger and
precedence is always given to
Allah and his messenger. The
statement here, oh you who have
believed, this articulates
whenever you see, oh you have
believed and then there is a or
prohibition after it. What we
understand is that the driving
force between behind fulfilling
this obligation, refraining
from this prohibition, the
driving force will be faith.
Amen. Amen. Will be the driving
force. Meaning that if I
fulfill this, and the more
perfectly and completely I
fulfill this, the more faith,
the more of faith I am. And the
more
strong and the more pure my is
and vice versa. We notice here
how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says do not proceed Allah and
his messenger and do not go in
front of, do not go on ahead of
Allah and his messenger. Allah
and his messenger, meaning,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
his messenger the authority of
the messenger, is in authority
the same as the authority of
Allah because the messenger
Tells us and relates to us the
will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says Allah whoever obeys
the messenger has obeyed Allah.
Because what the messenger says
to us delivers to us. We are
not inherently obey obeying the
messenger. He that he has some
kind of separate will. Rather
what we're saying is that the
messenger is a Perfect
reflection of the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Therefore,
we obey the messenger of Allah
in our obedience to Allah. If
we notice this chapter, this
chapter really has a lot to do
with etiquette. It has a lot to
do with etiquette. How to deal
with different how to give
presidents to different
authorities and so forth. This
issue of etiquettes and
manners. If we look at
this chapter we see that this
statement is repeated five
times. And each time comes up
it is a different etiquette in
dealing with a different type
of authority. So it comes up
five times. And this chapter
really revolves around five
types of
types of rights if you will.
The first is the right of
Allah, the right of the
messenger of Allah, the right
of or how to deal with those
who are sinful, amongst the
Muslims, those who are close,
amongst the, dutiful, amongst
our Muslim brothers and
sisters, and those who are
distant and far, amongst
Muslim brothers and sisters and
each time is repeated, a
different one of these is
mentioned. So, this first one,
the first is the right of Allah
that we are not to proceed to
anything. We are not to do
anything, to say anything
unless we know that it is
something that at least has
been allowed. It is something
that does not conflict with
what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is prohibited. And so, a lot of
times, people will get involved
in things, do things, perhaps
even get get a job or get so
entwined in something and then
turn around and say, well, let
me ask and see if this is
permissible or not, right? It's
not the time to ask and see if
that is permissible. Time to
ask and see if something is
permissible is not after you've
made the decision to entangle
yourself in this thing. It's
before you even get involved at
all. This is obey Allah and
obey his messenger. This is do
not proceed before Allah and
his messenger. Muhammad.